c'est d'accord que les syndicats de
police soient bien sûr voilà saint louis
et que le ministre de l'intérieur prenne
la parole pour camélia jordana raymond
je sais pas ce que tu en penses mais bon
à part sur moment qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit c'est très grave ce qu'elle parle de
massacre moi moi c'est moi ça me saoule
aussi d'entendre des gens comme camélia
là qui parle au nom des cités elle parle
au nom des six t elle moi j'ai passé
alors dit moi ceci dit moi si je suis
assez d'accord ça vient après ce que je
ne pense pas que camélia jordana elle et
elle et elle est plutôt tranquille
moi je me suis renseigné et tu ne sais
pas oui c'est vrai qu'on sait pas mais
je me suis renseigné son père et sa un
grand entrepreneur dans le sud de la
france à la londe les maures donc à la
grandi dans une maison dans le sud de la
france c'est parfait sur elle sa mère à
les chanteuses super pour elle
ouais à l'âge de 16 ans et gagne la
nouvelle star super pour elle elle fait
le festival de cannes
super pour elle elle sort avec des
people super port et pull vite son
métier d'artiste et chanteuse super
thorel
à quel moment à 6 heures du matin à se
retrouve dans le rer avec les freins à
la nation avec les gens de banlieue
qu'il soit disant sont censés se faire
massacrer
ouattara je sais pas où elle a vu que
les gens dans les cités se font
massacrer j'ai vu des débordements sur
twitter de policiers pendant le
confinement j'ai vu des débordements de
policiers quand il ya des mecs qui font
de la moto sans casque
à une heure du matin meadows où elle
parle des gens de citer ce qui m'énerve
moi c'est que sur les plateaux télé ils
sont tous là à parler de la cité mais
ils sont pas ils foutent de l'on invite
déjà ce thriller de bâle en tout cas moi
j'ai vécu 28 ans dans une cité et je
suis parti ça fait 15 ans je me sens
même plus légitime de parler de la
banlieue puisque j'y suis plus dès
qu'une banque m'a donné deux cent mille
euros en prêt pour aller acheter un
pavillon j'ai enlevé mes enfants de là
mais les gens qui travaillent et qui se
lève tous les matins sur ils prennent le
métro qui habite dans la cité qu'ils ont
affaire aux feux de poubelles pour
affaire aux ascenseurs en panne qu'on a
fait robrig la sq ont affaire aux
bécanes à une heure du matin
d'où elles parlent pour eux d'où elles
parlent pour eux les policiers protègent
aussi les gens des cités qui vont
travailler
il protège tout le monde alors il ya des
bottes des débordements il faut que ces
débordements ils soient punis on a vu
des vidéos qui circulent avec des
policiers à l'île saint denis qui avait
traité de [ __ ] ça ça doit être
puni medoukh toi tu arrives avec tes
tatouages et et bijoux pour nous
expliquer comment ça se passe en citer
faut pas faire des trucs comme ça parce
que c'est mettre de l'huile sur le feu
là on va en parler des heures tellement
ça alors alors alors justement juste je
voulais en parler moi moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on invite des gens justement ça
s'excite et voilà parce que c'est vrai
qu'on dit d'y aller et on va le faire
tomber si les démons
quinze des starlettes comme dire oui à
autre quelques nouvelles ont tout risque
la maison ça moi je veux des gens qui
sont vraiment dalli cité que jean
tremblay avec des boucles de 15h invite
mois des mois des mecs de 20 ans qui
habite dans une cité charpy 20 ans un
bien vite - des citoyens qu'on 50 ans
qui veulent la paix dans les cités qui
veulent juste aller bosser élever leurs
enfants invitent moi ces gens là par les
tocards comme ça quand au festival de
cannes je dis moi je dis ce que je fais
mais c'est alors regardez christophe
castaner qui donnait une conférence de
presse ce matin
il est revenu sur la polémique
différence de presque 6 mois bernard
montbernard 1 mais je te dis franchement
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur c'est
camélia jordana à quoi je suis excusé
moi c'est pas voilà encore même ça
aurait été gérard depardieu je te dis
bon d'accord tu vois tu peut-être lui
répondre mais camélia georges chez
laurent ruquier café si je regarde ses
ardeurs et sport si tu veux mais les
jeunes en mairie mais non mais on n'a
rien contre elle mais là sur le fait que
les banlieues vas-y dans leur grade
supérieur
et après tu parleras 30 secondes tu dis
castaner kastler et désamorce une
connerie qui a été fait c'est ça une
connerie qui a été fait mach au soir vis
publique à la télévision française avec
un libraire qui parle avec elle et moi
j'étais étonné j'aime bien laurent
ruquier aux grosses têtes
j'étais étonné qu'ils disent rien j'ai
l'impression qu'ils avaient pas de
présenter altérer la séquence elle dure
l un sur l insulte la police française
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas elle
parle de massacre et son service public
y'a rien ça stay et ça laisse un
libraire qu'il aura avec le festival
kann d'un corner à des conneries comme
tu dis une castaner qui a obligé de
parler et elle qui dit à castanet on va
se voir sur un plateau on va débattre
sur un peu toi j'ai fondées ou non mais
t'as raison avoir donné où il va
débattre avec camille nage mal à se
rappeler toutes plus